the sixth episode of the mandalorian
second season
chapter 14 the tragedy was an
action-packed installment sure to please
boba fett fans
and as always there were plenty of
easter eggs tucked away in the margins
here are a few you may have missed tease
at the beginning of the mandalorian
second season
chapter 14 finally brought boba fett
back to the forefront of the star wars
universe in grand fashion
he not only reclaimed his armor but also
took the fight to a platoon of hapless
stormtroopers
reminding everyone why he's considered
the most ruthless bounty hunter
in the galaxy still while this wasn't a
specially big return for boba fett
one couldn't help but notice how the
memory of his father jango fett
dominated much of his screen time this
is evident first when mando questions
him on his mandalorian heritage
boba fett replies i'm a simple man
making his way to the galaxy
like my father before me fans of attack
of the clones know that this is
reminiscent of a conversation that
django had with obi-wan
where he said i'm just a simple man
trying to make my way in the universe
additionally boba mentions that much
like his ship slave 1
his famed arm is set as a hand-me-down
once belonging to his father
fett also explains to mando that
contrary to popular belief
jango didn't steal it rather he earned
it years ago during his days as a
foundling
boba says his father jango even served
during the mandalorian civil wars
an event alluded to now and again in the
clone wars animated series
the conflict was a reason for the divide
between sateen cruise of mandalore
and governor preet vizsla of concordia
after mando recovers his best scar spear
boba fett says he wants mando to take a
look at something
then presses a spot on his armor just
above his wrist a sequence of texts
written in the mandalorian language
flashes into the air
boba explains that's his chain code
which has been encoded into the armor
for 25 years
the audio description on disney plus
calls it a lineage tree
as boba points out the code mentions
both him and his father
but what about the other lines star wars
fans online made quick work of
translating the chain code into english
it's incomplete but some of it makes
sense from left to right it reads
foundling took into the year the concord
dawn
mentor just father fett boba fett
but what does all that mean first
mentioned in the clone wars and first
appearing in rebels
concord dawn as an outer rim territories
planet led by fen rao mandalorian
protectors ruled concord
dawn in the age of the empire on concord
dawn the empire crossed paths with rao
and fellow mandalorian warrior sabine
wren who gave the darksaber to bokehtan
before it somehow ended up in maf
gideon's hands additionally
concord dorm was the home planet of
reiko hardin a bounty hunter known as
the marksman of concord dawn who once
tried to assassinate obi-wan in an
episode of the clone wars
concord dawn is also allegedly where
jango fett himself was born
according to the canon reference book
star wars the complete visual dictionary
new edition
the mentor jazz part of the lineage tree
is likely a reference to justin mariel a
mandalorian warrior also born on concord
dawn
and an important figure to the phet
family in legends canon
mario first appeared in the comic django
fett's open seasons in 2002
initially serving as a journeyman
protector a low-level cop essentially
but real wound up killing a corrupt
high-ranking officer driven by his
unshakeable morals
for this he was exiled from concord dawn
and eventually joined the mandalorians
mariel later rose in the ranks to become
the sole leader of the mandalorian
people
he established a mandalorian honor code
resulting in tension from the new
mandalorian group and the death watch
splinter terrorist group
led by the vicious tor vizsla when war
erupted mourinho headed back to concord
dawn where he saved and orphaned django
fed from a death watch attack
mario became django's adoptive father
and mentor but was killed six years
later
by vizsla django later avenged mariel's
death
then rose to become the new leader of
the mandalorian people
there were a few minor easter eggs
hidden in chapter 14 worth mentioning
boba fett says that the appearance of
moth gideon's light cruiser isn't a
spice dream
a reference to spice the most popular
illicit substance in the star wars
universe
first mentioned way back in a new hope
the drug is a staple in star wars
stories
and the pivotal part of solo was even
set in a spice mine
blue butterfly-like insects similar to
the one flying near grogu
appeared on endor in the battlefront
video game series and a slightly
different blue species appeared in the
clone wars
the e-web heavy repeating blaster used
by the stormtroopers in this episode
before it was crushed by a raiders of
the lost ark style runaway boulder
first appeared in the empire strikes
back at the battle of huff
and finally the design of those dark
troopers sure called to mind tony
stark's iron man armor especially while
in flight
this makes sense of course considering
iron man director and happy hogan
portrayer john favreau
is the showrunner for the mandalorian
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mandalorian are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one